happy to be here today to talk to you
about type safe machine learning
orchestration with flight and pandera
before i jump in
my name is niels bentilan i'm a machine
learning engineer at union ai
where we're building
what we think are next generation tools
for machine learning operations
a little more background about myself i
have a background in biology and public
health
i
kind of fell in love with coding and
data science and machine learning and
have now found myself building tools to
make
ds and ml practitioners more productive
so the crux of this talk
is
that type safety is a critical feature
of orchestration tools
that deal with data and machine learning
and
just to level set with everyone i'm
maybe preaching to the choir here but
just to set a baseline
types are
types define the set of values that data
can take
but they also define the domain of
operations that we can perform on that
data
so if you consider the set of integers
or strings you know these are infinite
sets but
you know here are some examples
depending on the programming language or
mathematics that you that you're using
adding two integers is well defined one
plus one equals two
however
the operation of adding 1 plus the
string a is undefined
and similarly if you try to compute the
mean over a collection a list of
integers that's also well defined you
know the mean of 1 2 3 is 2.
and unless you're using some kind of
deep learning vectorized
representation of strings
in some embedding form the mean of a b a
c is
similarly undefined
so types can be simple
you know in strings floats things you're
probably all familiar with
they can be more complex
like lists events
dictionaries mapping strings to floats
dictionaries mapping strings to list of
floats etc
and so to give you maybe a more real
world but still kind of toy example
let's look at
housing
this is the california housing data set
you can access it on sklearn it's one of
the built-in data sets
and it's a data set containing about 20
000 instances
where each row in this tabular data set
is a
district in california and each variable
each column
is an attribute about this and typically
people use this in regression problems
to predict
median house value i think it's in there
somewhere
so if we look at the first set of values
just eyeball the first set of values of
this data set
you can already as a human being who you
know programs you may program you may
have seen this data set before you know
what floats are you can see
that you can kind of start inferring
what the types are you know so all of
these
columns are floats
but you know if you know a little bit
about the world you can also say the
range of latitude is between negative 90
and 90 and you know the range of
longitude is negative 180 to 180.
and if you look at the rest of the
variables it's kind of meaningless to
have negative number of average bedrooms
so okay these are floats
aggregate values per district
and they have to be positive
so this is all kind of swirling around
in your mind
and if you extrapolate this to more
complex data data that changes something
that isn't static in a toy data set
we all
can know you know if you are a data
practitioner in in some form or another
you know that enforcing and maintaining
data quality
is very challenging
and since this is a talk about ml ops
i'll tie this problem
to problem number two which is
production machine learning has a
complexity problem
you might be familiar with this
graphic
i think it was in a paper that google
put out a few years ago about technical
debt incurred by machine learning
systems and i think this is probably
well before
the sort of
maturing uh ecosystem of ml ops tools
and data tools that we see that we have
today
but really the main point of this figure
is to say you know the ml code in that
little black box
is just a small piece of the ml system
puzzle
you know you so you have data collection
data verification monitoring all these
pieces
now
how do i know if these components
are compatible
you know you might write python code or
whatever
language you're using you might write
all these pieces and modules and you'll
connect them after the fact
into your own pipelines but how do i
actually know whether whether they fit
together nicely
and to answer this question i'm going to
go back to the very basics of
programming of
a program
taking some inputs and producing an
output
so in a machine learning training module
your input might be a collection of
features and labels
so pairs
and your programming your program might
be a learning algorithm that learns how
to map those features to those labels in
supervised learning
in this case your output
is a model artifact and this is a model
artifact that you can use in another
setting
namely serving or prediction
right so now your model which is the
output of this first pipeline becomes
the program of your you know inference
or serving pipeline
which takes in
input which is the features
and output which is the predictions that
you'll use in your downstream business
case
now notice
we can also say a few things that are
implicit in this diagram which is the
features in the in the original
input feature label pairs
that needs to probably be the same type
as the features going into this serving
pipeline
to hence all the feature store kind of
products that you're seeing now feature
store tools
so
really the premise of my talk the thing
that i want to convince you of if you're
not already
is that strongly typed
strongly typed interfaces unlock static
analysis capabilities
that push many potential errors from the
runtime context to the compile time
context
and i'll
define these as i go and as i as i talk
through my next points
but my main point here is that if you
have strongly typed interfaces when you
combine that with a few other features
i'll show you later
you actually can enjoy a lot of benefits
and these benefits i'd like to talk
about in terms of what
as a practitioner myself what are the
properties of an orchestration pipeline
that i would like to have
so
i would like as a human being or machine
to be able to tell what the component
types input types and output types are
so you know i don't i don't know if
you've heard this quick before but if
there's no type system or type
annotations you're emulating a type
system in your brain you're trying to
say oh what is this x
i don't know it could be anything you
know
you know with python's duct typing which
got it really far
this is sort of a different philosophy
of
explicitly stating your types even
though there might there might be you
know you have a union of many different
types
i also want it to be reproducible so if
an error occurs at the interface
boundaries of of my different components
i want to be able to reproduce it and i
want the guarantee that
if the error occurs i can
re-run it and then debug it you know
locally
there are also some nice efficiency
gains that you can get in combination
with other features like caching
so if i want to determine whether
i should hit the cache or recompute the
value of some component some function
i can first check for changes
in the function signature before
checking the actual values
and in terms of parallelization
before i try to concurrently apply a
function to some collection of inputs i
can check whether the type signatures
match
now the last two properties i'll talk
about is i want to be able
to
uh when a pipeline fails to be able to
see
you know pinpoint the cause of the error
and understand how to address it
and finally
in a related way i can understand i can
understand how some downstream artifact
came to be by looking at the processes
upstream processes that produced it
so here comes flight
which is a data and machine learning
aware orchestration tool with type
safety built into multiple layers of the
software stack
with flight you can easily compose
workflows using tasks as building blocks
you know you pip install it
here i'm defining just three tasks
they're just functions you decorate them
with that task if you've seen other
orchestration tools this should look
very familiar i think we're sort of
converging to this on the similar syntax
and then the workflow at the bottom is
looks kind of like a function but in
flight it's actually a dsl it's a graph
that
compiles into
a you know into some other format that i
don't want to get to and this get into
in this talk but it basically constructs
a dag based on the function and
the function invocations with the inputs
and the outputs
so let's return to our california house
price data set
we're going to formulate a
regression problem here with a target of
median house value at the very bottom
and
with every all the other variables as
features
so this is an actual flight dag um i'll
show you the code in a second but this
is a high level overview
where
see if i can use this boom we're first
grabbing data
we're then summarizing
the training and test data so the data
get data set will actually produce your
training test partition
you're going to train the model in the
training partition and then evaluate the
model on both train and test partitions
you'll say you want to assess the degree
of overfitting
now before i get into the code i'm just
going to tell you what types we're going
to use so these are kind of like the
type building blocks
that our task building blocks are going
to use
in the top you see a data set
this is all you know flight syntax and
it's very it just uses regular python
constructs so we're saying the data set
is a data frame
with these fields and these types
this is not a type but this is just a
global variable that just says what the
target
is one part of our pipeline is going to
split our data into training and test
partitions
and the training result will be a ridge
regression model with training mean
squared error and test mean squared
error
finally in the bottom are hyper
parameters to the model so here's an
alpha value for regularization
cool so now you know we have our types
we're going to use those types
in defining our tasks i'm not going to
go through laboriously
you know enumerating all these tasks but
as you can see
all of them are have all of them have
type annotations both inputs and outputs
flight will not know what to do
with inputs that are not typed
it will know what to do with untyped
output is just you know kind of a none
no op basically
now
we've designed defined our tasks
let's put it all together into a
workflow
and
you know it's it's pretty
readable i would say
um
but this is the thing that flight
compiles
into this dag
and because flight is strongly typed we
can auto generate strongly typed launch
forms so this is a launch form on the
flight ui for launching this training
workflow
as you can see here the model hyper
parameters
it knows that the default i set for you
know the meaning of life
for the random state
thank you for that
and
we didn't set a default for the alpha
value so you're going to have to set
that
i was talking about other features that
work well with this so
each task you can think of as a
containerized unit of work
and that has really nice reproducibility
guarantees so as long as your task is
item potent you're not relying on some
random
maybe you're setting your random state
within the task you can be guaranteed
that your task is completely
reproducible with all its dependencies
source code etc
now
the the i'll get into some of the kind
of debugging benefits here
so
flight will barf
if the types don't match so here i've
intentionally
changed the data set input type of train
model to a dictionary
and flight says well i don't know how to
convert this data frame schema type into
a dictionary so you know
fix it before i even you know launch the
workflow or put it into production
but obviously you can't always catch
everything because within that task
function body there could still be
exceptions so
the local debugging experience is
because tasks are just python functions
you can just run them locally and in
your new unit test suite you can
try to catch
data corruption or other types of errors
but even the case that those kinds of
errors went unexamined and you've put
something into production
flight will happily tell you where
exactly
that error occurred
it'll give you a nice error message this
is the same one we got locally that you
know i've intentionally removed this
latitude column
to cache the outputs of your tasks is
quite straightforward
you add the cache equals true
flag in the task decorator
and this cache version
gives you control over when you want to
invalidate it manually
so if you've ever been in the situation
where you're you know you're running a
model and you know it's taken a week to
run and you're like oh yes i'm looking
forward to the results
and then ah your evaluation
module had a bug in it
well
you know this is the error
the thing you can do is you can just fix
the bug on that last component
relaunch
your workflow
and this is an indicator in the ui that
says all the previous components in this
pipeline are cached they didn't change
the inputs didn't change
so there you go
i'm going to start
right where i left off
also if you look at this code if you're
thinking in python
you're thinking that these two calls to
summarize data will happen sequentially
and these two calls to evaluate model
will happen sequentially but that is not
the case when you put this register this
deploy this to a flight cluster this
will actually
both be called
concurrently so these two will happen
around the same time these two will as
well as long as there are the resources
available for it
and here static type checking
applies you know to these parallelized
invocations of a task
so
if i were to change the summarized data
type to from a data set to a dictionary
we see a familiar type error here saying
hey i'm calling summarize data set on
this train data set which is a data set
but it's actually expecting a dictionary
so you better fix that
now
in terms of data lineage
right
the flight ui gives you the capability
like many other orchestration tools to
be fair
that
say you have a mean squared error
evaluation metric
and i'm curious okay what what were the
hyper parameters what are the artifacts
that produced this metric
i can look at the inputs that went into
it so this is one of the the trainer
test partition this is the model and
this is the s3 path
that
contains these artifacts that stores
these artifacts
and i can go
upstream into the upstream processes and
do the same thing inspect the inputs and
outputs
see what parameters i that
were that produced the data set et
cetera
cool so like i've basically thrown a
bunch of features at you that flight
does
but what about data types for machine
learning
so this is where pandara comes in and i
don't i think i failed to mention
earlier that i am the author of pandara
um it's an open source data validation
tool that's
kind of
i hesitate to use the word pythonic but
i'll say it anyway i've kind of tried to
design it to be as pytonic as possible
where you kind of i'll show you in a
second how intuitive it is to use
but the way i frame it is it's a
statistical typing and data testing
library for data frames
providing tools for defining types
for complex
data containers
and then also unit testing your
pipelines with them
so there are these two terms right
statistical typing and data testing
i think they're worth getting into
so
statistical typing is extending the
primitive data types to have semantics
about collections of that type
so if you consider a single data point
right in our example
we have latitude longitude and some
other features
what can we say about the single data
point
we can say what the primitive data
primitive data types are
we can express some kind of constraints
like value ranges
allowable finite set of values
regex string match
nullability
however if you look at a collection of
data points
first of all you can apply those atomic
checks at scale
you know so if you're using something
like pandas or moden or pi spark or
something you can then apply those
atomic checks you know to very large
data
but something you can't do
with just the
with the single data point is you can
assess uniqueness right this is kind of
like
i wouldn't say an emergent property but
it is only a so it is a property that is
only meaningful with collections of data
same with monotonicity
you know your friends mean median
standard deviation classic descriptive
statistics
maybe normality checks chi-squared tests
things like that
fractional checks to say you know i
expect 90 of my data to be of some
property
and the thing to notice here is that
statistical properties by definition can
only be verified at runtime
i only know whether something is a
normal distribution by looking at the
actual values
however we can also define functions
that use statistical type annotations
that verify valid operations on those
types going back to my
type definition in the beginning
and the second term i mentioned data
testing i think is a huge component of
pandera
so it lets you validate not only real
data
but also the functions that produce them
so in the real world
you have some raw data you make a schema
for that you validate that you have a
function that then transforms that raw
data you want to also validate that
but in your unit test kind of ci
pipeline
you want to generate test cases
to make sure that the transform function
is doing what it's expected to do
i'll show you a nice feature with data
testing but first i want to introduce
you to kind of the syntax and how you
define these schemas so if you've used
pedantic or data classes before this
should look very familiar
pip and sol pandera
and then you inherit from this schema
model class
and each class attribute is then a
column or a field
you say it's a series this also supports
panda pandas indexes by the way and you
say what type it is
you type annotate it with this data
frame the special syntax i won't get
into too much but you're saying it's a
data frame conforming to the schema
you slap on this decorator and this is
just python code right this has nothing
to do with flight
but it plays well with flight really
well so all you have to do is install
this plugin
import it into your script
and you know your task functions will
automatically
use the pandaris spec and validation
routines to validate the data
okay so that was a very toy very much a
toy example a quick start example
this is
a schema for the california housing data
type right so we can now talk about
types for these you know multi-field
columnar data sets
as you can see i've put the latitude
longitude constraints that i mentioned
and here i'm just putting up reasonable
upper bound on you know how many average
bedrooms can you know i think a million
is pretty good
upper bound
and here's our target variable
median house value how am i on time
i'm good
and this coerce
flag basically says
before you apply these validation checks
to the data frame coerce all of the
columns to these specified types so you
know you don't you won't have to call as
type or you know manually coerce the
columns anymore
now one thing i want to highlight here
is this
this is actually
i've had
a i spent a lot of time trying to think
about how to express statistical
distributions and statistical checks in
pandara
the initial try was kind of unwieldy and
weird and no one uses it so
actually in preparation for this
conference i think this is a pretty good
way of doing this and this is
this is a custom check this is not a
built-in check in pandera basically i'm
saying i expect the mean of median house
value to be 2.0685
i got that value by manually inspecting
the data exploring it computing the mean
right
how do i write these custom checks and
this is
really the crux of pandora's to make
custom checks
very easy to write
so
custom checks are just functions
ignore this one first this gets get a
little complicated but the mean equals
function check
takes in this series pandas object
and uses the scipy library to do a
one-sample t-test
on the series
and the null hypothesis is that the mean
of the data is equal to the value
argument right this value argument
and if you're familiar with statistics
they like a lot of double negative so
i have to read this out every single
time if p value is greater than alpha we
can't reject the null hypothesis so
meaning that it's in the expected
distribution
this mean equal strategy
this is a way to take the parameters
here of value
to generate data
and this actually uses the python
package hypothesis which is a
property-based testing tool
and we're using numpy here to generate
random
this is a random variable to generate
data
given the parameter of value we could
extend this with standard deviation too
but you know this is a simple toy
example
and this is a syntax to register the
custom check
so that i can actually
use it in the context of my schema
okay so i've shown you the basic syntax
i've shown you how to customize it
what do you get
so this is pandara with flight
and this is the flight ui
i've
uh intentionally introduced data
corruptions here so again our our poor
latitude column is missing again um
so this is a pandara error message so
the way pandara works is you say
schema.validateddataframe it'll return
the valid dataframe
for you if it's valid
tautological
and it will raise an exception
if
it finds any failure case
so what other kind of failure cases can
you see
so this is complaining that the data is
the wrong type i introduce a bunch of
strings here and
slash a and pandara is saying you know
hey i expect latitude to be afloat but i
couldn't coerce these values
and again here it's telling you exactly
where the failures happened these are
the original index values for that data
frame
you also know when your data has the
wrong values so the similar to the
previous slide but this is outside of
the range of negative 90 and 90 for the
latitude column
and finally with our custom main equals
check you can see whether
our data passed that hypothesis test
so now because i spent so much time
explaining what this mean equal strategy
is this is it in practice you know so if
you've ever despaired at writing oh i
need to write this neither hand code
this
data frame mock data frame for my unit
tests well
despair no longer
you can take your schema
call the dot example method
and it will generate
data that's valid under your systems
your your schemas constraints
i'll show you how to use this a little
bit later properly in unit tests but
all of what this is all of what i'm
trying to say is you can test your data
the functions that produce them
so this is a pi test unit test that
tests the happy path case
and then test all the random corrupt
data corruptions that i've done
and this doesn't use the data synthesis
by the way so this is just calling
functions
where i've introduced these corruptions
and i'm asserting you know what the
expected error messages are
and you can also test the artifacts that
they produce so this is a unit test for
my train model function
this is important so i'll kind of go
through each line
basically i'm using this given
decorator which is a hypothesis library
thing
and i'm basically telling it hey take
this california housing data turn it
into data turn it into a data synthesis
strategy
pass it into my pi test function
and bam you have your data
i can call my training train model
function on it
and then now i can assert properties of
my model
i didn't make a schema for the model
predictions but you know you could if
you wanted to
so
turns out i'm going to have some time
for questions but
the three takeaways i want you to take
from this talk is that flight is an
orchestration tool
that
gives you type safety
and type safety is really deeply
integrated with a lot of its features
which provide
benefits relating to reliability
efficiency and auditability
with pandera you can ensure the quality
of data flowing through your pipelines
and you can ensure the correctness of
the functions in those pipelines by
expressing statistical types
and finally if you combine the two
you can build deploy and scale these
machine learning pipelines
while enjoying the guarantee that when
things go wrong and they will
you'll know exactly where the error came
from and give get some hints get some
hints about how to fix it
so in the flight roadmap we're going to
focus on better reporting so flight
decks is a thing we're building to make
customizable reports for artifacts and
data structures that flow through the
flight tag
ml awareness tools
features like inter-task model
checkpointing and data labeling
and service serving integrations with
you know many of maybe of the tools that
are talked about today integrate with
them for model serving
and on the pandara roadmap
i'm going to focus on extensibility
so support for x-array json schema pi
arrow basically kind of like the data
container ecosystem in python
adding more built-in checks and
statistical hypothesis checks
and getting more interoperability with
the general python ecosystem in general
so there is a fast api integration that
you know i'm talking with the author of
that to figure out what to do there next
um obviously pedantic and pi test as
well
and if you want to learn more here are
some resources i don't know if the the
slides will be made available they
probably will but on flight you can go
to flight.org
um visit our docs in the repo
and pandara is at pandaria dev pandara
on github
and the docs
cover way more features that i've than
i've explained here
and you can contact me at neil.union.ai
my twitter handle is cosmicp boy
thanks so much for your attention and i
hope you learned something new today
[Applause]